an attack on the most innocent two
newborn babies and their mothers among
those killed at this hospital in Kabul
soldiers rushed to save more tiny lives
even as the gun battle rages when the
firing started we went to the safe room
there were nine of us inside the safe
room for four hours the attacker came at
the back of the safe room door and fired
but he couldn't enter the room the
assailants disguised themselves as
policemen before opening fire to hit a
maternity clinic shocking even for a
country that's no stranger to war and at
a time when it's dealing with the corona
virus pandemic the Minister of Public
Health as an impartial institution and
it is staff members condemns this event
and we call on all parties involved in
the battle in Afghanistan to respect the
National international treaties which
preserves safety and immunity of the
hell personnel and health staff members
and health facilities staff - in eastern
Afghanistan a suicide bomber struck at
the funeral of a police commander in
Manga ha the wounded rushed to hospital
for treatment no one's claimed
responsibility yet for either attack the
Taliban denies involvement Islamic state
also in the frame
the Afghan security forces now ordered
into offensive mode the prospects for
peace more precarious than ever even as
many US troops prepare to withdraw
Deborah Haynes Sky News